they almost Miss really creating new
original content cuz they're too busy
reacting they're too busy pocket
watching every other content creator
known to man it's doing pretty good it's
better than any of your videos yeah
that's for sure I mean wait what is the
biggest YouTube video you ever dropped
was it Vape Nation back when you were
like still kind of culturally relevant
yeah well it was cool cuz you used to
make stuff and now you just critique
stuff and there's a big difference
between people like me and people like
you yeah what happened I think everyone
that's your fan wants to know where did
it all go wrong I think people are
pretty happy I don't think so I think a
lot of people I mean if you look at the
cultural relevance and contributions I
mean you were contributing and now
you're just kind of
after yeah well well here's where it is
was it the money or was it the
thing it funny if you just answered the
questions